very frizzy hair today we're giving I
put a metal fork in an electrical socket
ooh oo ooh speaking of stylish this
might get weird merch look how cute it
is Link in the description didn't
totally have a plan what else is new
this upcoming Wednesday will be my fifth
round of chemo that is insane and
exciting and wow five of six so we are
tumbling down the hill to the finish and
tumbling is correct today I feel really
good feel almost like a bit unnerving am
I allowed to feel this good in this
process that's just a bit of the anxiety
that comes along with all of this I
haven't really updated too much about it
because for a while I was out of
commission this round was tough which is
hard for me to remember now because I
feel really good and now even trying to
say this out loud I'm like was it that
bad was it that bad and then I look at
my journal and I read some things and
I'm like oh it was that bad I just
wanted to update you on like physically
and psychologically where I'm at and
also note some products that I've been
using that I've enjoyed that you
unfortunately if you have to go through
this similar process might be interested
in using Andor if you know someone going
through a similar process might be good
gift ideas and that's really the thing
when you get sick everyone wants to help
but there are limited tangible ways that
you can help someone that's sick and
Hank actually did a really great video
about what to get people when they're
sick and what to avoid getting people
when they're sick and I thought it was
very thoughtful and spoton as a
currently sick person I don't know what
I'm going for here but I enjoy it okay
round four round four wow this round was
a bit of a physical struggle and also
much more of an emotional struggle than
the other rounds have been you know
2third of the way done you're doing
really great but you still have a third
to go so you just sort of reach that
emotional plat of being over it wanting
to be out of it overwhelmed with the ick
of it so in the beginning I remember a
lot of people saying make sure that you
let yourself feel everything that you
need to feel all the good emotions and
all the bad emotions don't be afraid to
be angry in this process and I you know
read all of that and I cognitively
understood it but I was like I'm not
really an angry person when I'm sober it
didn't really connect with me
immediately about connecting two
feelings of anger through this process
however this
round yeah I was very on guard about you
know recently recovering from SE so I
was constantly worried about relapsing
which caused a lot of anxiety you know
you blend two paint colors and you make
another paint color it was like the
anxiety and the frustration combined and
I did feel angry and I was like oh this
is what everyone's talking about I'm
pissed that I don't feel well the
Amnesia of all of this is a wild Factor
because I sit here and I'm trying to
remember how bad it was because my brain
has let me forget already but in that
bad time my brain also forgets that that
bad time will be over eventually so this
round was frustrating just the feeling
that I could not get on a level ground
with my stomach and I was very hesitant
to take em modium because the EM modium
the last time around was keeping all of
this infection
inside of me and so my association with
a modium being gatekeeper for the ick I
had to like decondition myself while
feeling sh physically lots of crying
this time around I did the LMC method I
let myself cry whenever it came up like
emotional burps the tears would come I'd
cry for like a minute and then it'd be
okay and then maybe later in the day I
cry for like 5 minutes and then I'm okay
releasing emotional gas throughout the
day and that really seemed to help so if
you're struggling perhaps let your
eyeballs burp out some water and see
where that gets you cuz like I didn't
even have the energy with my anger and
frustration to like punch a pillow I was
like this
flaccid body on the couch with all of
these intense feelings the only way I
could release them without exhausting
myself was crying which also exhausts me
a little bit your emotions are like a
dog that has to take a sh go let it out
let it out in the yard relieve itself
and when it comes back it's going to be
one happy dog not my strongest metaphors
but I'm also not my strongest self right
now this round I let myself just be
pissed off a little prissy pissy passed
out princess on the couch I was also
getting very worked up about not feeling
well because I had to go do a biopsy for
these calcium deposits that they found
in my left breast behind the tumor sight
and I knew I had to physically get
myself to this biopsy and I was worried
that I was wasn't going to feel well
enough to go and I didn't want to have
to reschedule it but come Wednesday I
was feeling okay enough to go so we went
and let me tell you about this biopsy
I'm still waiting on the results for it
makes me a little nervous to talk about
something that is kind of up in the air
right now but my whole experience of
Life currently is up in the air right
now so I guess it doesn't matter that
much it's a fun little story I told it a
little bit on my Instagram the day that
it happened because I just it was
unexpected and unbelievable I written
about this on our patreon I've learned
that I can expect what I expect I don't
want to say that I've learned to expect
the unexpected because I feel like
karmically that is inviting twists and
turns and surprises into my experience
and I don't want to invite them I just
want to recognize an openness to adapt
to things that are not what I expected
because this biopsy ended up being
something I did not expect I've had two
biopsies before this and both biopsies
were pretty similar you go into a room
you lay down horizontally you put your
arm over your head of the area they're
biopsying doctor comes in does some
general Small Talk the doctor for
instance the time before told me he
liked my shoes they were leopard print
just a moment of humanizing each other
before this man I don't know it's a
giant needle in my tip they do local
anesthesia so the area is numb but your
eyeballs are open and your brain is
there you do not get knocked out for
these the first time I got my biopsy I
didn't know what the hell was going on
and I didn't want to Google anything cuz
I didn't want to freak myself out
because my imagination fortunately and
unfortunately is one of the most
powerful parts of me but I probably
should have because the thing that I did
to myself was make myself grossly
unprepared for the physical nature of
this experience I went in stone cold
sober they poked around a lot it was
crazy feeling it lasted longer than I
thought it was going to last and when I
got out of there and into the car with
LA I just started sobbing because it was
so much more intense then I prepared
myself for Preparation is like a life
hack so the second time I got a biopsy I
took an anti-anxiety pill I was ready to
be awake but potentially not present and
that biopsy went fantastic that was the
one where the doctor complimented my
shoe so it started out on a good
foot so I'm thinking I'm going into a
biopsy similar to the last one I've been
to so I'm going to take another Adavan
I'm going to go lay arm up I'm going to
let them compliment whatever they'd like
to compliment on me and I'm going to let
them do their business and then I'm
going to walk back out to the lobby and
meet my husband and he's going to drive
me home and I'm going to be tired but
accomplished see I'm very good at
predicting my own future that future
didn't happen lovely nurse brought me
back let me change into a beautiful pink
gown and then she brought me into a
mammogram room and a mammogram room is
different than a biopsy room a mamogram
room is a small room with a big ass
machine that has little handles like
this that you put your boob on and it
squishes it and takes images it's like
the biggest panini press you've ever
seen and when she led me into the room I
said to her oh I'm actually scheduled
for a biopsy today I think like I'm
correcting this nurse on what's supposed
to happen and let me tell you I am not
the kind of person that tries to correct
a nurse but I had already taken my
Adavan in the car and so my guards were
down a little bit I didn't have anxiety
filtering my thoughts going from my
brain to my mouth she said yes you're
scheduled for a mamogram biopsy and I
said what's that which should make sense
as the words stand a mamogram biopsy
you're getting both a mammogram and a
biopsy at the same time in my wildest
dreams I never thought those two
experiences could be sandwiched into one
experience they are two different
experiences one your boob is getting
squished and photos are being taken
another one needles are going into your
boob and things are being pulled out how
we combine those
two it ends up being something like this
and that's not what I was planning on
getting at the breast cancer center that
day I'm going in there then she said for
a mamogram biopsy you're going to sit up
in this chair here and then we're going
to push you into the mamogram machine
and they're going to do the biopsy with
you in the mamogram machine and and I
said oh okay as if it made sense to me
it did not make sense to me so I sit
down in the chair and then she takes out
a towel and she puts it across my lap
and says and I quote this is for
spillage oh oo ooh o I think I've only
ever heard someone casually use the word
spillage on like a game show like double
dare they're doing the biopsy inside of
the mamogram machine while I'm sitting
up like this
there's a towel on my lap for
spillage I felt like I was being seated
front row at a Gallagher show so I'm
sitting with the towel on my lap and she
says I'm going to go check on the doctor
she's just finishing up another biopsy
and then we'll be in here and ready to
go meanwhile I took my Adavan in the car
ride over it is now kicking in I've
already been in a Kemo fog but now
there's a Harry Potter invisibility
cloak slowly falling over my face As I
Disappear more and more from the present
moment but now I'm very relaxed and
panicking because now I realize that in
this situation I can't just lay down and
let this medication keep me calm while
they do their thing I need to be sitting
up and actively holding my body in a
position that allows my breast to sit on
the mamogram machine while they do the
biopsy I need to be an active
participant of this experience and I
have actively taken medication to do the
opposite for me about 20 minutes goes by
I am just experiencing the most chill
sense of panic the Adavan has only
kicked in more while I'm waiting for the
doctors I'm a sleepy lady but now I have
to sit up in this machine and get cut
open the Adan adds a less and relaxing
layer to this situation I thought I was
just going to lay down and
B go for it I'm in a bit of a situation
finally that nurse comes back she comes
back with another and then the doctor
comes in this beautiful woman in a dress
that puts some scrubs on puts her hair
in a hairnet and is perfectly polite and
cheery and upbeat and is like are you
ready to go and there is limited time
for me to understand the situation
before now I'm being pushed into this
machine I have no shirt on I'm just
vibing as they position my boob onto the
mamogram smooshing board they smoosh me
in and then they crank it so it's really
smooshed in because I have a small
smooshy and the calcium deposits are so
close to my chest wall they need to get
me in this machine as much as possible
so they position me with my arms over
top of the machine and my boob in the
panini press now I've assumed the
position I'm trying to hold on and hold
this position for dear life fighting my
anti-anxiety medication I'm trying to
stir up anxiety as much as I can in my
body to keep me alert and awake and able
to do this ripping the machine like this
trying so desperately to put my tiny
breast offering to this medical Dragon
mouth they tell me they're going to put
the local anesthesia in and then one
nurse just comes around to the front of
me and goes like
this she just offers me her hand and I
take her hand and I'm holding this
woman's hand while they're putting a
needle in my boob and I'm just sitting
there thinking God when was the last
time I've held an adult woman's hand I
don't even know but you know what this
is nice I thought there were a lot of
people in involved in this process when
I saw three of them come in but this
woman's whole job is just to hold my
hand this whole time I'm a bit of a
awkward non-touch non-physical person
but holding this woman's hand gave me
such calm so I'm bracing for dear life
my lower back is like seizing because
I'm so clenched and I don't want to move
because if I move and my breast moves
and we have to reset me that's not going
to be fun for anyone like how I imagine
old timey people had to stand still for
old timey photographs I am holding this
position I'm also holding this adult
woman's hand and I'm also having like
side anxiety of like is this how you
hold a hand I haven't held a hand in so
long am I holding it right am I holding
her hand weird meanwhile I'm completely
topless and there's needles going into
my boob but I am worried about the
correct way to hold this adult woman
nurse's hand the needle goes in they say
you're going to feel pressure they put
the local anesthesia in and then they're
trying to do the biopsy I'm not looking
at any of this but biopsy needles I know
are long I do not like needles that are
short I don't like needles that are long
I don't like needles I can barely
tolerate a pine needle they're not for
me I feel the biopsy needle go in the
left side of my boob I feel it go all
the way through and touch the right side
of my boob at that point I feel this
wave of sweat and heat start Rising
through my body and I realize I'm going
to pass out I feel the faint Rising like
vomit in my body and I just look at this
woman while I'm holding her hand and I
go can I have a water like a scared
little girl holding her mom's hand at
the dentist she goes yes she gets me a
water she comes back I drink the water
and I feel the faint going back down
into my body they leave the room they
check the images they come back in and
they're like we did it we got the images
we can take you out of the machine they
take me out of the machine and I am just
like I'm sitting in the chair I don't
even want to look at the towel I don't
even want to know if there was spillage
to their credit they did it fast that
felt like it was under 5 minutes uh
thank God they were excited that they
got the images and then they were like
you know we were really nervous that
needle was going to go straight through
on the other side and I was
like I don't know these women well
enough so I have no idea what the humor
to seriousness ratio is so to this day
I'm still not sure if that was a joke or
not and I don't think it was I think
that was a genuine concern which is wild
and I understand the spillage towel the
woman bandages me up with an ice pack
and she says you can get changed and
whenever you're set it's that double
door over there back out to the lobby
that's the craziest part is that they
just send you back out to the lobby by
yourself so I walk through these doors
back out to the lobby I'm just holding a
nice pack and I look like I've been
through a traumatic experience and I'm
walking out to Elliot was in the lobby
playing his video game and he just looks
up at me he's like what did they do the
and I just look at him and I'm like that
was crazy but it was okay I'm really
glad we successfully were were able to
do it that was a wild experience and
again another situation in which I can't
expect what I expect still waiting on
the results but wow we made it through
so if you find out that you are going to
get a mammogram biopsy just know it's
not the same as a biopsy and I hope that
they give you a nurse whose seemingly
sole responsibility is to hold your hand
because that honestly was such a
specifically tender and helpful gesture
I don't know so what would have happened
if I wasn't holding her hand maybe that
just speaks to a broader lesson of
reaching out to each other in times of
need anyway you want to talk about some
products and Sh and maybe some cancer
capitalism for a second do want to tell
you just quickly about a few little
products that have been really helpful
to me you guys know that I love beanies
I am a Beanie Baby one of you out there
left a comment about satin lined beanies
that are more gentle on your hair hair
and ooh did I go to Amazon and scoop up
two of them immediately and thank you so
much for that comment they are so
comfortable I feel like these are better
options for your hair regardless of
whether you're going through
chemotherapy I got these on Amazon like
I said there were a ton of colors and a
ton of options and they were pretty
cheap a lot of people have asked about
my eyebrows and eyelashes during this
process the cold capping only works for
my head during this process I was fully
anticipating
losing my eyelashes and my eyebrows so I
got my eyebrows microbladed before I
started the chemo process and then
someone on Instagram left me a message
saying that they use this product called
Brian Joseph's lash and brow
conditioning gel they used it through
their whole chemo process and they
hardly lost their eyelashes I said this
on my Tik Tok as well I'm doing some Tik
toks guys I without doing any research
bought this product immediately it seems
a little unregulated and potentially
homemade but the reviews of it are
really really good I started using this
like 2 weeks before I started chemo you
put it on your eyebrows and on your top
lash line every single day that is the
caveat that has to be used consistently
because if you stop using it the chemo
drugs that are still in your system will
get into your hair follicles and your
lashes and eyebrows will fall out this
is my second tube it's not cheap I think
it's like 40 or 50 bucks it's been 3
months and I'm a tube and a half in some
Fallout of my eyelashes and some Fallout
of my eyebrows but this seems to be
working it's not guaranteed people have
different results and everyone's bodies
react differently so it's one of those
things that I'm just going to keep using
it until it stops working and I've been
hesitant to recommend this in the
beginning because I didn't know if it
would work but it seems like it's been
working for me so knock on wood it keeps
working so far so good we'll see and
then quickly some face stuff my skin
texture and like the quality of my skin
has definitely changed to the chemo
process and that's normal for everyone I
was Googling like skin products that are
better for those going through chemo
found this brand called Lindy l i n Di
and they make these little packs of skin
care specifically sensitive to those
going through chemo I love this face
serum that is Citrus which doesn't make
me nauseous I'm no skin expert at all
whatsoever this is just what has kind of
been enjoyable for me like I said it
comes in like a travel pack with a bunch
of different products so it makes a
great gift if you know someone that
could use it and then the other brand
that I've been loving I found this brand
called by Sarah London it's a little bit
more expensive and it comes up when you
look up skincare for Kimo skin and I've
been using this face oil every night
before I go to sleep and sometimes
during the day when I'm not wearing
makeup and it's just so pleasant and
their face wash cuz their face wash is
super sensitive and I don't believe it
has any odor to it which is really
helpful for people going through chemo
that are super sensitive to Smells I got
this back in like August
maybe and I still probably have like a
quarter or a third of this bottle left
so it goes a long way okay I think that
is the update I'm going to find out
about that hilariously intense biopsy on
Monday and then Wednesday I'm going into
round five and I'm feeling so much
better you know they know what they're
doing by giving me 3 weeks off it's like
they've done this before I have like a
week to a week and a half that is
absolute and then I start to feel
better and I don't know what to do with
that feeling because that feels
unnatural to feel good in this scenario
and then I start to feel almost dare I
say normal which I know is not normal
because I am so far removed at this
point from what I understand my normal
Baseline to be and then I'm going to go
do it again next Wednesday and then
we're going to go through this whole
wild high high Low's cycle again and
then after that we're going to have one
more and then we're going to be done how
crazy is that so feeling good but
definitely navigating some more
difficult emotions in this round which
isn't surprising but is just there
reminder to feel all of your feelings as
you're feeling them get your emotional
gas out that's how emotional science
works or something okay that's the
update for now thank you guys so much
for watching and for all of your
messages they are so helpful in a way
that I can't fully articulate at this
time so thank you and for those that are
going through this process we're doing
it we're doing it one day at a time one
wacky traumatic biopsy at a time it
wasn't that bad we did it it wasn't that
bad it all happened so fast that's it
I'll see you next time I turn this
camera on